18 ans depuis quelques jours et condamné
à la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
patrick est depuis hier soir le plus
jeune condamné à perpétuité en france
il n'avait que 16 ans au moment des
faits oui 16 ans lorsque patrick tu as à
montigny-lès-metz deux petits garçons
âgés de 8 ans ont retrouvé leurs corps
le crâne fracassé à coups de pierres
hier soir les jurés de la cour d'assises
de la moselle ont refusé à patrick
l'excusent de son jeune âge
jean-jacques bazié et faire 3 lorraine
patrick avait 16 heures le jour du
double meurtre de montigny-lès-metz à
peine majeur pour son procès il est
devenu après deux heures de délibéré le
plus jeune condamné à perpétuité de
france à huit clos les jurés placé
pendant trois jours devant les cinq
grosses pierres qui ont servi à
fracasser les têtes de cyril et
alexandre place et aussi devant les deux
vélos avec lesquelles jouaient les
enfants le jour du meurtre
les jurés n'ont reconnu aucune
circonstance atténuante ni excuse de
minorité
à l'annoncé du verdict la salle est
restée silencieuse et patrick n'a pas
manifesté la moindre émotion
il a simplement déclaré je suis innocent
je suis sincère une innocence qu'il
clame depuis deux ans après avoir dans
un premier temps avoué le double crime
sa seule arme judiciaire désormais un
pouvoir un cassation que son avocat
maître baker peut déposer dans les cinq
prochains jours si l'on patrick sera
transférée vers le centre d'orientation
de fresnes avant d'être incarcéré dans
une centrale
le système judiciaire français ne
prévoyant encore aucune peine
incompressible
patrick peut espérer sortir dans quinze
vingt ans il aura alors la quarantaine